hola buenos dias angela bueno las
temperaturas al fin y al cabo controlan
casi todos estos fenómenos si pensamos
en las sequías cuanto más alta sea la
temperatura más transpiración
evapotranspiración hay lo que influye en
que haya menos reservas de agua de agua
potable en ríos y lagos y demás no hay
más temperatura acumulada en el océano
lo que hace que los huracanes sean más
fuertes las estaciones duran un poquito
más te das cuenta los veranos son un
poco más largos el otoño no dura un poco
más la primavera llega un poco antes lo
que hace que la temporada de fuego sea
cada vez más más larga no este año hemos
visto temporadas de fuegos como no
habíamos visto nunca inundaciones en
europa que han sido enormes o en otro es
cierto en otras regiones son las sequías
sin precedentes pues todos estos cambios
que vemos en nuestro planeta vienen al
final controlados por la temperatura del
planeta
bueno y qué podemos esperar ver entonces
en el futuro en términos de temperatura
y de eventos globales
ahora lo que sabemos esta temperatura es
consecuencia de nuestras acciones
entonces si nuestras acciones no cambian
lo que lo que podemos esperar es que
todo continúe en la misma línea otro
decías antes esta década ha sido la
década más caliente y los últimos ocho
años que tenemos al registro son los
últimos ocho años más calientes de los
últimos 140 años que venimos controlando
entonces si nuestras acciones no cambian
lo que esperamos es que las temperaturas
sigan creciendo y que esta tendencia de
cambio climático de temperaturas altas
siga cada año la misma línea no importa
si es el año más caliente o el segundo
año más caliente en el registro lo que
importa es la tendencia a largo plazo y
eso parece que no va a cambiar y muy
rápidamente le pregunto cómo ayudan los
satélites para este monitoreo y para el
control del cambio climático bueno
cuando cuando medimos la temperatura
podemos medirla desde superficie y está
muy bien pero si pensamos en nuestro
planeta tres cuartas partes del planeta
son océano y es muy difícil para
nosotros llegar así medie sin embargo
desde el espacio podemos tener un
control absoluto de todo nuestro planeta
y monitorear tener tener datos de todas
las regiones del planeta incluidos los
es utilizando misiones como lanzas que
lleva ya casi 50 años tenemos un
registro consistente y continuo de los
últimos años de todas las lecciones del
planeta y podemos ver dónde sube donde
baja ligeramente la temperatura cuánto
es en épocas cada año y eso nos permite
una visión que desde tierra no podríamos
tener pues alfonso le agradezco mucho
por las aclaraciones y que tenga un
feliz día